hey guys and welcome to a brand new
video today's video is going to be
another subscriber Milestone video and
uh what the mil one is is we have
reached 7500 subscribers and you might
be wondering hey Robin why didn't you do
one for 5,000 or for 4,000 okay so what
we're going to be talking about today is
uh little story of mine that actually
got mentioned in a comment section uh I
guess a couple weeks ago and that is how
I uh failed my biggest flip uh of my
flipping career in my actual life and
not even RuneScape I would have made at
the current prices about
$500,000 uh us um unfortunately I sold
it back in the day for
about $200 I believe and for those who
can't guess what that is this is a story
about uh Bitcoin and uh
in its infancy the Bitcoin was worthless
and for any of those who follow it now
it's worth thousands of dollars uh so
yeah if you're interested in the story
and uh a little bit of agility on the
side stick around otherwise thank you
guys so much for the 7500 Subs means a
lot and uh we're looking like we'll get
to 10,000 in the next couple of months
and that is going to be so exciting all
right let's get started so when I
originally bought the Bitcoin it was
about January of 201 11 I originally
bought it was about
410 Bitcoins at the time it was worth
about uh 30 cents us per Bitcoin uh and
luckily at the time uh the Canadian
dollar was much stronger as well so
actually that cost me about well 125
Canadian and it would have been 125 us
as well uh because the economy had been
well even between North America not
North America can in the United States
uh for a couple months at that point uh
so yeah I originally bought about $ 125
uh dollar with the coins which was about
410 Bitcoins now the way you actually
got Bitcoins back then or at least the
way I did it uh was really convoluted
and kind of confusing but I'll go ah and
explain it for you so originally take
the money from my bank account into a
PayPal account and most people know how
to do that uh but from the PayPal
account you'd have to transfer it to a
trading platform now the one I used I
believe was called verock I can't I
don't know how you pronounce it but it
was like some v's and some x's anyway
from there You' get a balance on this
trading
website so to get Bitcoin you could
couldn't actually trade directly from uh
US dollars to bitcoin you had to trade
between a second currency first and the
one uh that was allowed was actually the
second life currency uh it's a video
game a virtual reality video game that
has a economy all to its own so I
remember the currency was called SL or I
had a different name for it uh but
anyway it's just the virtual currency of
the game so from there you would
transfer US Dollars into SL currency and
from there you could transfer it into uh
Bitcoin so you'd always lose a bit on
each transaction and they' take a
service fee but in the end I ended up
with about 410 Bitcoin so now that i'
had finally uh gotten some Bitcoin uh in
a virtual trading platform then you had
to send the Bitcoin to whatever place
you wanted they had different Bitcoin
addresses which looked kind of like hash
codes or hexadecimals they're just
really long strings of numbers and
letters and that's where you'd send your
Bitcoin back and forth uh so
unfortunately the biggest issue with
this flip is that ended up uh selling
the Bitcoin uh trading the Bitcoin I
didn't really have much left when it
came to the point when it was actually
worth1 hundreds of dollars thousands of
dollars uh to begin with I ended up
trading a lot of it I bought some stuff
with it and while I did deposit money
into Bitcoin all I was really left with
were crumbs and different uh Payment
Processing platforms Bitcoin exchanges
and Bitcoin wallets uh so didn't really
have any Bitcoin left except for rag tag
amount in different places uh so when it
came to about uh the end of one of my
college years and that was in uh 2013 I
guess sometime around April uh was when
Bitcoin really started to take off uh
initially in February March it was only
worth $20 per Bitcoin and I considered
trying to just get it out I just to get
a little bit money left so I think I may
have had I guess I had
about well I didn't really I I probably
had just a Bitcoin in total not a whole
lot uh So eventually uh when I came home
from school one day I saw a bunch of
news articles it Bitcoin was spiking up
to a all-time high I was worth about
220 us per Bitcoin uh which was 10 times
the amount it had been even weeks ago uh
if I recall correctly so at that point I
did manage to scrape together all my
Bitcoin from the multiple different
wallets I had a couple of them wouldn't
even let me take it out so I actually
did have probably maybe I think I one of
the payment processors had like 1.2
Bitcoin left in it
uh some of them had a little bit more
but uh they ended up being less than
trustworthy and just took everyone's
money when the price started spiking a
really popular thing in the early days
of Bitcoin was exit scams and still are
of course
but who's going to give everyone back
their money when they probably had
millions and millions of dollars uh
worth of people's money and it's a
decentralized currency so it's even
harder to track down where your money is
who owes your money and whatnot
uh anyway so I did end up managing to
trade it back in got about $200 back my
PayPal and I thought that was a good
day's work I needed well I didn't really
need the money but I wanted the money
and I didn't really think the price was
going to keep going back up and yeah
that was that I thought so unfortunately
for me and very fortunately for a lot of
other people uh Bitcoin continued to
rise it peaked in uh November of that
year at almost $1,000 and then it
crashed over the next uh year so then
now it's reached a all-time high uh back
in March of about
$1,200 as of today it is sitting at
$1,199 us I mean if you take that
multiply it by 410 you're getting about
492,000 uh US Dollars uh take that and
convert it to um Canadian and you're
getting like
6 40,000 Canadian uh well I mean I'm not
going to I probably wouldn't have gotten
that much I mean there's lots of fees
and stuff but um and realistically my
money would have been stolen probably by
then but still uh it does upset me some
days to think about it but it's not
really upsetting me too much because it
was a long time ago it's like it's not
like this happened over the course of a
week or two that Bitcoin had long been
spent out of my mind I thought I got a
good deal at it for it at the time so is
there a lesson to be learned here uh not
really I mean there's no way to really
have known that Bitcoin would reach such
ludicrously high amounts uh I mean some
people got became millionaires off of
this and some people uh got enough money
to pay their hydro bill I mean it's not
like worth worrying about uh yes I'm
salty and butthurt about this and but
only when I think about it it's like you
know when you get those memories of
something stupid he did uh just in the
middle of your day and then you just
feel really shitty and depressed for
like 5 Seconds and then it goes away
that's kind of this and eventually it'll
fade from my memory entirely all right
guys so I hope you enjoyed the quick
little story and uh the 7500 sub special
now I have one other question for you
guys uh maybe more what your guys's
opinion is on this I have another idea
for another series um but to kind of
make room for this series I would have
to change one of the existing ones don't
worry I'm not removing any of it uh
here's my idea I was just wondering what
you guys uh would have think about it uh
so what it would be is a GE only uh
Series so it would start from a brand
new account uh free to play or pay to
play yet to be determined and I would uh
train my skills anything that can be
done at the GE so I mean buyable skills
uh flipping moneymaking and eventually
once I got to a certain total level I
would unlock um maybe the Barac Palace
or something like that where unlock
different zones of things near near the
gr exchange so maybe at like say 300
total level I could go into the Rock
Palace there I could train my magic or I
could uh train my combat skills or uh
even the construction building is pretty
close by I mean there's lots of options
and uh but it' still be kind of
centralized around the grand exchange
and money making and flipping stuff like
that so what i' be changing and not
actually really changing at all is the
road to one bill I would keep the name
but um the focus would be more on just
progressing the account cuz honestly
that is what it's been for the last 3 or
4 months uh the focus hasn't been on
increasing my cash tag it's been on
progressing my account that's what i'
I've been enjoying about that still the
end goal would be one bill and I'm still
not really going to change much about it
uh but the focus wouldn't really be in
the end on different money-making
methods more on progressing my account
up to levels where I could pvm for money
or just do late game com uh content to
eventually get the one bill as opposed
to doing little Nifty money makers and
flipping uh anyway what do you guys
think about that I would appreciate if
you left a comment down below uh thanks
for watching all the way through and
really appreciate the 7500 Subs that's
it guys so I hope you enjoyed the video
and I'll see you guys in the next
one